Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for being here today for our 110th episode!
BAU BAU! 110!
Yeah!
We're back, Ruffians!
Hooray!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Wow, we're Ruffians here today!
Joining us for the first time, let's explain what FUWAMOCO Morning is!
Wow, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You're on the right paw.
Already?
Our job's done then, Moco-chan.
Bye!
This was FUWAMOCO Morning!
We just started, Moco-chan.
We can't end.
It's been a little while since the last FUWAMOCO Morning because we went on a little bit of a trip.
Our first trip had two FUWAMOCO Mornings this week.
Yeah!
But we missed you, Ruffians.
Although we did talk on Wednesday, FUWAMOCO, so... But we'll get to that later.
Yeah, let's see what today has for us.
Ruffians.
Your eyes are pretty sharp because...
There was another Pero Sighting.
Why?
Ruffians, you need to stop running into him, okay?
I feel like there's just more and more Pero Sightings.
There's enough for me to do, Moco-chan.
There's something going on.
I feel like I told you, Ruffians, stay away.
Make sure you have pudding.
But... Let's see this time.
Where was he seen, huh, Ruffians?
De-den!
Oh, this is quite the different Pero Sighting.
You tried to calm him down with some yarn, but he absorbed it.
Huh?
What the heck?
I know you know.
He kinda, maybe looks a little bit cute like this after maybe just a bit playing with the yarn, but he's not a cat, you know.
Pero can't be this cute.
No, no, I don't know.
But you're in a good interest, Pero, you know.
Pretty.
Yeah, he is pretty.
Pudding!
Right!
Yarn!
Not yarn.
But, you know, Ruffians keep on mentioning it to you, but maybe if instead you actually give him some pudding instead of yarn, he wouldn't be in this situation, huh?
Yeah, but I mean he does look pretty happy having some good tunes to listen to from your headphones, huh?
That's true, just your headphones are gone now.
They're his.
Well, I guess you can always get some cheaper ones, and... Yeah.
He's just happy maybe being a little... He is now!
He's listening to Lifetime Showtime!
He better be.
He's very cute.
Yeah!
Yeah, just this once.
BAU BAU!
Just this once.
Just this once, okay?
Early, got it?
Early acts alone.
Well, that's what we wanted to mention, Ruffians.
Well, you know, we just got back from our trip together with Abyss!
And, wait a minute!
We're all ready to sing together!
To sing for you, Ruffians!
Because we had our first off-collab karaoke stream!
Right after, you know!
And we sang a bunch of songs earlier!
You know, a lot of anime, game, vocaloid songs.
Yeah, vocaloid too!
In case you missed it, it's archived on our channel here, so please check it out, okay?
Yeah!
We really wanted to make sure you know that we could save the memories for now, you know?
Yeah.
We could watch it over and over again.
Then we'd go anywhere.
Yeah.
But it was really, really scary.
And we had such a blast all together with everyone.
It was a good one, you liked it?
Yeah.
Ah, you watched it!
BAU BAU!
There's too many songs we wanted to sing.
Right!
You know, Advent was like, oh, let's sing this one, and let's sing this one, and let's sing this one, and this one too.
If we're gonna sing this song, we have to choose from these other three.
Yeah, we actually chose way too many songs, but... Now I'm thinking we didn't sing enough.
So... It's an important chance together.
It was really important to us, so... That's why we wanted to organize it.
Right, yeah.
And it was our dream for a long time, too.
Was it on our goals list?
Probably.
Sirens!
First Rebellion, now Sirens.
What did you think, Ruffians?
Gonna hear maybe a little bit, you know what the tease is.
Do you feel teased?
Just like that.
That's how it goes.
It sounds goofy!
I thought you said goofy!
Not goofy!
No!
The opposite of that.
Yeah.
It's really, really cool.
More super fancy.
It's exactly what's in the trailer!
It's not a goof- Although there is one part that's kind of goofy.
Right, Moco-chan?
What?
There's one part that's kind of goofy.
I don't think the Ruffians will be able to hear it though until you maybe listen to it 20-50 times over.
Right?
You gotta listen with your ears, okay?
But it's really fancy, not so goofy, so we hope that you'll look forward to it.
It'll be releasing very soon, so please join us during our first anniversary of collab with all of us on Sunday on the 28th.
at 8pm PT, not 6pm PT.
Oh, and for FUWAMO fans out there, maybe you haven't seen the teaser yet, or maybe you want to see it again, you can find it on Twitter on the hololive English Twitter account.
FUWAMOCO, we were tweeted too.
We're also on the hololive English YouTube channel as well.
And you know, as for the upcoming Advent with anniversary collab, the off collab, you know, there's been a bit of a change of plan there.
So yeah, it's two hours later than expected.
We hope that you'll be able to stay up just a bit later than usual on a Sunday night for it.
I know it's rough.
It's rough, but... Yeah, I think there's some exciting things planned, and maybe downslides, things will change, and... Thank you for understanding, Ruffians!
Yeah, you know, especially for Ruffians further on to the other side, you know?
Thank you!
It'll be a really really special first anniversary for sure!
BAU BAU!
You know, not just a first anniversary together with Advent, but the Ruffians being together!
That kind of celebration comes a little bit later.
BAU BAU!
At this event, everyone builds their own homemade figures for all its kits!
And you know, they display them and sell them too!
Yeah!
It's a super creative event!
And we always love seeing what kind of special figures everyone is making!
You know, usually the kits are only made in very small amounts.
Lots and lots.
Yeah, yeah.
And you have to put them together and pou-
Paint.
Pound, pound, pound.
Paint them yourself!
Pound, pound.
Maybe there's some pound, pound, poundinging the pieces together.
If they don't fit.
When it comes to the airbrushing, right.
But it's so amazing!
We love one thing so much.
There's always so much to look at!
Right!
Ruffians!
This year, this Rufffest, there's going to be a very special FUWAMOCO figure that's on display!
Look!
Oh my gosh, Ruffians!
Yeah, it's a family figure!
Thank you so much, FIGZOO!
Now FIGZOO will be displaying the completely painted and assembled kit that they made from the ground up of us and Perroccino.
She's a mom, though.
Yeah.
Right?
It's amazing, right?
Kawaii!
Yeah, kawaii!
You know, all the... This is just made of love.
It's completely made of love.
Completely from love.
And some passion.
Yeah, and heartbreak, and sweat, and definitely some tears too, you know?
It's so beautiful!
I love it, I love it.
Can we look at it closer, Moco-chan?
Look!
So cute!
Amazing!
Right?
I love my poses too, it's very FUWAMOCO-chan!
The base, it's a bit nasty.
It's kind of like a plate too, right?
A plate with a petal there looking at you.
Hi, girl.
What?
A petal.
And you have nice shoes and a paw print!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Let's take a look again.
Just like that!
You see, we're on the pon-de-rings.
Moco-chan's tummy is kinda... Wow.
What about my tummy?
I don't know.
You know you're not supposed to touch.
No touching.
No touching the figures.
Moco-chan's tummy might be different.
Yeah.
So... Sexy Pero!
Pero sexy!
He's just sitting there.
He's not doing anything.
He's just like... Right.
Pero ero.
What?
Ruffians, there's probably many of you who'd like to get their paws on this kit and assemble it right!
Yeah, cheeky.
So, I think that, you know, there's probably even more Ruffians who would love to have it as a pre-painted scale figure.
I don't know, but there's something special about garai-shiki, too.
They both have their own... their own... miryoku.
Their own... attractive points.
Attractive points to them!
FUWAMOCO, of course we'd absolutely love to have something like this beautiful and cute in our collection!
Yeah, I don't think we can stop staring, huh?
No.
Thank you so much for making us into a figure!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Alright, the shipping, yeah!
You know, once it's assembled, it's kind of assembled.
But you gotta be careful.
It's more dangerous.
Very delicate, you know.
Very, very delicate.
Gotta be careful.
BAU BAU!
Let's look at photos!
I hope I can see lots and lots of photos from all different angles!
Yeah, any photo of me!
Please take photos, okay?
No low angles.
I miss you deshita.
BAU BAU!
Like we kind of mentioned, we're back from our first trip since we debuted.
Our little vacation.
Little vacation, right?
We had a Twitter space instead of FUWAMOCO Morning Wednesday, but I don't know if Ruffians were able to listen in.
I know it's a bit tricky because it's not YouTube, it's Twitter.
Yeah, and Twitter's a little bit funny sometimes.
Yeah, but we were chatting together with Biboo and Nerissa!
And while Shiori was really angry, my kawaii senpai too!
She was out.
Yeah, she was really out.
We're all in a ryokan that we're staying in.
A ryokan is kind of like a Japanese inn.
But a lot of times, they have an onsen.
It's a really big one.
Yeah.
It's an onsen with a big, you know, natural spring bath.
It was so much fun!
We're just really happy that we could spend some down time together with all of them.
Yeah.
You know, we still all had homework to do.
So we're like, I just woke up.
I'm like, I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm like, you know.
No, so what about this, huh?
Yeah.
But we went on lots of adventures and went into lots of baths.
Yes!
And Ruffians may be not too familiar with onsen.
But, you know, it's a natural spring bath and you can't bring anything in- You can't wear anything in there.
In anime, sometimes I wear a towel.
No.
The towel you can kind of bring with you, but you can't put it in the water.
No bathing suits either!
So first, we went in a tiny bath.
Altogether, it was probably sized for three to four people.
I think it was for four people.
There was other things around that kind of made it seem like it was for four people.
True.
Yeah.
It was a bit tiny.
But it was good!
Nice!
Yeah!
And I poured cold water on Biboo unexpectedly!
And then I drank a little cold water.
Advent soup.
No, the water is clean.
Yeah.
You didn't drink the water that you poured on Biboo.
I poured the water and then the remaining water, I drank it.
I didn't pour all my water.
You know there's a bunch of different ones and you know there's an outdoor one so you can feel the, what would normally be cold air.
But there is a bit of a happening.
Yeah, you know, the outside sometimes there's bugs.
And... I was on one side of the bath, and Nerissa and Calli-senpai were talking on the other side of the bath.
And I saw there was this big flying ant on Nerissa, on her arm.
So I was like, okay, I'm not gonna say anything, I'm just gonna walk over to her and hit it off with her.
And maybe I got a little bit too excited, and I kind of really slapped her.
That was the most impressive slapstick.
What did you do that for?
I thought I just snapped or something, right?
I probably thought you were just walking over and be like, hi!
Right!
I'm gonna sit over here and you just know I'm gonna smack you!
Right?
I don't know where the bug went, but it disappeared.
No problems after that.
Yeah.
Bueno, eso.
It's okay.
It's either the bug or it's Fuwawa.
She kissed it better, it's okay.
But speaking of kisses... Yeah.
You know, we had lots of food.
Yeah.
Yeah, shabu shabu.
We had just a few snacks.
You know, some sweets.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
I think both Biboo and us, we had a lot of sweets.
Maybe got a bit...
Yeah, yeah.
I saw my Biboo just going around giving everybody kisses.
But then she forgot you.
She forgot me!
I was all ready too.
It was cute to see her go around the table and be like... I'm ready!
She looked like a little penguin.
Right!
Going up and giving grandma's kisses kind of feel.
Yeah.
You know, we got to cuddle on the futon together.
Cuddle puddle!
Yeah.
We're looking all at Twitter together.
Yeah!
I walked over and I just see them all.
Twittle.
Konbini.
They had a seating area, so you know.
We just sort of hung out.
Yeah.
Had snacks.
Yeah!
At the konbini.
Yeah.
We're like, wow, this is really relaxing.
Yeah!
It was a nice, quiet konbini.
Yeah.
Just chilling out at the konbini.
That was an adventure.
A cat book.
Yeah!
Look at the cat book.
We're like, this is my favorite cat!
Yeah.
Those kind of things.
Nobody strange is a crowbar.
No.
We're the strange people.
Yeah.
And it was interesting too because we went to the onsen!
Yeah!
It was one time, you know, we had a bunch of homework that we had to do and we couldn't go together with them all into another one of the onsen.
So we heard later that there was a cold bath!
A cold bath!
And we were like...
And it was really tiny.
A tiny cold bath.
Yeah, so all four of them all kind of jumped into it and went like thigh to thigh.
Cold bath, right?
Yeah.
And there was some grandmas that walked by and they were like, huh?
No.
I know.
And then when we went down next morning to take the bath.
Yeah.
They're like, there's the cold bath.
And then we looked at the sign together with Calli-senpai and Nerissa and we're like, uh, this isn't a bath!
This is just a little pool that you can take cold water in to splash yourself after the song.
Yeah, it says, please use the little, the ladle.
It didn't say don't come in here.
Yeah.
Definitely wasn't a bathroom.
No, it definitely wasn't a bath!
Yeah!
Lasting Impression, right?
Yeah.
We went in the sauna.
Yeah!
Nerissa and Calli-senpai!
I did not go in the sauna.
It's too hot!
No!
Yeah.
Nerissa was like... She was only in there for a couple seconds.
And then Calli-senpai and I were in there.
We were talking about anime.
I beat Calli-senpai.
I stayed in there longer.
Yeah!
I didn't give in.
It was very hot though, it's hard to breathe.
It's too hot.
It was really fun!
I really hope that, you know, we can go back together with everyone soon.
I liked our adventure at the conbini.
It was really fun!
But now we're back, Ruffians!
Our adventure to have even more fun together!
The sonnet isn't a competition!
No, it's a competition.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
We wanted a vlog.
A vlog!
See, we wanted to do that.
We wanted to do stuff like that.
Yeah.
But we want to- This time it seems like it was kind of a little bit difficult.
That would've been nice though.
Maybe next time!
We'll have to see.
BAU BAU!
Two spaces apart.
Maybe different parts of it.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
That'll be fun though, you know?
You can see what breakfast is like with Nerissa.
It's always very interesting.
Yeah!
Yeah.
It's fun.
We all share food.
Yeah, Biboo eating tamago kake gohan for the first time.
Yeah!
Karin-senpai teaching her how to do it.
You know tamago kake gohan is where you put a raw egg on the rice and you eat it.
Yeah.
Biboo liked it too.
I wanted to try the Calli-senpai method, but I was full.
Morning for you too.
BAU BAU!
Why is everyone so funny?
But, let's see who's the Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan.
Alright, Doggie of the Day is... It's Charlie!
Charlie!
BAU BAU!
Look how goofy she looks!
Right!
Alright, I'll sort of...
Is she up there with the blanket?
Yeah, so many blankets there with her.
She looks very well-loved.
She's like, oh, what are you doing?
Taking a photo of me?
Really?
I'm a little bit embarrassed.
Right?
So cute!
Ball of love.
But those ears are very beautiful, right?
Kind of makes you want to touch them.
As long as they're not my ears.
I like your eyebrows.
Oh, the eyebrows!
Wanna touch those too, right?
Moco-chan, how does Charlie BAU BAU?
Are you sure that's not Bousouzoku?
No.
It sounds like a motorbike.
It's not a motorcar.
Not Mococar.
No.
It's Charlie!
BAU BAU!
I think we can all see that Charlie is very content.
You know?
She's so sweet.
She gets to go out and walks all the time.
It's a Ruffian too!
How nice, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Yeah.
You know that probably gives lots of hugs.
Yeah, lots of hugs.
Maybe, maybe some treats.
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't think it gets much better.
But, you know, maybe if she got some extra tweets, extra headbutts... I mean, we could get those instead.
BAU BAU!
Charmy's so cute.
Good life.
BAU BAU!
And next for our Today I Went On A Walk, we have... De-den!
Sukira!
Is this a walk?
You know, if you see the cicadas on your rock, right?
Yeah, but wow, that's a lot of legs.
It looks like a very fresh and tender cicada though, huh?
Yeah.
What?!
It's a cicada!
You get to see them, but not us!
We've been searching everywhere, right?
I know, it's shedding!
You know, we thought maybe we could find them near the onsen, but... We've looked in the trees.
I don't know.
I feel like, you know, this one's so fresh, it would blend in well to the glass.
Right!
But I guess, you know, it's going to harden up and then become brown like the tree bark, too.
And then it'll be hard to find again, huh?
Right!
No, don't hurt it!
Give it to us!
Yeah, you know.
Then somebody can enjoy it, right?
Yeah.
Enjoy.
BAU BAU!
That was a nice discovery, huh?
Right!
Nice.
I kinda wanna pet a Enola.
I wanna see Enola!
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day we have...
De-den!
In the early days, you wanted to bring Pero back.
You even went to the BAU Games to find him.
But with every episode, your relationship with him seems to get worse.
What happened between you and him?
It's been a hundred plus episodes, and he still isn't back.
Do you still want him?
Are you sure about that, Pero?
He's been around, you know, right?
It is.
But he's not nasty.
Maybe.
Sometimes it's important to look past all the nasty things he says to us and how mean he is to all the Ruffians too.
Is that okay, Ruffians?
You know, you smile.
It's not a danger at all.
It's okay.
He's not our mentor.
He's our pet.
Our pet.
Don't listen to what he says.
Listen to what we say, Ruffians.
Yeah, okay.
It's time to put him down.
Wait!
That's a bit far.
He lived a very long time, okay?
I don't think that's possible.
I don't know, I wasn't considering that.
He's Uncle Pero, that's too much!
Okay, that's going too far.
That's gross.
That's gross, Ruffians.
I don't know.
He's the best, we love him!
Well, if that's the case then... Maybe... If that's the case then... Maybe it would be a bit... For fear... If that's the case then... Oh?
Oh?
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
What's the problem?
What do you mean what's the problem?
It's because Pero, the Ruffians seem to really like Pero.
Even though Pero's so nasty to them.
Pero wanna protect your smile.
No.
That's true.
He does!
I don't think he does have rage in his mouth, okay?
Yeah, he... Pero's just nasty.
He wants your pudding.
That's it, Ruffians.
He's not here to protect anything.
He's here to take.
And you know... Any cute girls too.
There wouldn't be any of that here, right?
Yeah, Pero's nasty.
He's nasty and we're gonna continue treating him as he deserves.
Maybe?
Not so fluffy and fuzzy?
Yeah.
Pero can go out to ch- Wait!
Moco-chan, let's be fluffy and fuzzy to Pero and then you know we can get him to help us.
Vaginitis, you know.
Kinda getting in our way, right?
Maybe that's okay.
Yeah.
Good idea.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, you know, justice is gonna get in our way, you know?
We're having so much fun here!
Free from the cells!
Bye.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for always being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning together with us here!
We're always waiting for your submissions!
You know your doggy have a day of walks!
Going on walks.
Thank you, Ruffians, for always sending us your walks.
We love seeing where you go.
Questions!
You know, there's so many things going on.
Cool things.
Please let us know if you have any questions for us.
And use the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
We're also looking for scoops that you can submit to us with the hashtag FWMCScoop.
And if you see anything interesting going on in hololive English,
BAU BAU!
And we have another stream coming up very soon!
We have... De-den?
De-den!
It's been a little while since we spelt.
Right?
What do you mean?
You know, we kinda take some shortcuts, you know, instead of going F-U-W-A-M-O-C-O, just F-W-M-C-Y.
M-O-C-O-C-O!
That's true, maybe Moco-chan's good at spelling.
Yeah, I can do it.
We'll see how it goes, Ruffians, but we're gonna make sure that we get lots of rest so that we can spell the best possible, right?
Let's hope.
B-E-S-T, best.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Oh, I'm ready for another trick question if they're like, how do you spell same?
Huh?
S-A-M-E.
Yeah.
Samae.
BAU BAU!
Maybe we need to get that rest, huh?
And our schedule!
On Saturday, starting at 6pm, it's gonna be a big special stream because we're having a Super Mario World in Dallas!
And we're gonna be playing on the SNES with, you know, a cartridge that's even older than these Demon Dogs.
Over 2,000 years old!
Don't tell Nintendo about the really, really old cartridge.
It's okay.
And we're gonna be there for the very first time!
Hasn't been done, not together with Mama Puppy.
Yeah, there's been a lot of raging, so I shouldn't be even bored this time, huh?
And hopefully the controller lives.
As well as our fingers.
BAU BAU!
It's going to be our longest stream yet.
We're amazing at it and sometimes we beat it.
That would be kind of weird, wouldn't it?
BAU BAU!
And then on Sunday at 8pm PT, different from the schedule here, we're going to be having our Advent Off-collab first anniversary stream!
And after that, wait, it's a question mark?
Maybe you can put together the pieces, maybe you can't.
Either way, it'll be a great surprise!
Surprise!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning.
And Ruffians, you know who I want you to archive today.
Here is your FUWAMOCO Award!
It's BAU BAU brand new song!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU, we hope you had a wonderful FUWAMOCO Morning together with us Ruffians!
Sure, sure, sure.
Feeling a bit more fluffy and fuzzy now.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
See you on BAU BAU!
Zura!
BAU BAU!
Mofureko.
Sonic Mastix 2008.
BAU BAU!
Margeus Jones.
C-D-O-C-D-O.
BAU BAU!
Skulls.
Ikoike.
BAU BAU!
Watcher of the Abyss.
Armando.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!